[Aplausos]
hoje cada um de vocês vai ter que fazer
uma escolha
eu quero que vocês decidam o que você
prefere
você prefere ganhar um milhão de reais
hoje o que você ganhe um centavo que vai
cobrando pelos próximos 30 dias o que
seria sua escolha
eu sem dúvida alguma
escolheria a primeira opção 1 milhão de
reais é claro mas eu digo escolheria
porque aconteceu uma coisa na minha vida
que mudou totalmente a maneira de
enxergar as coisas e foi por causa disso
que eu decidi que a partir daí eu seria
1% melhor a cada dia
todo mundo aqui conhece alguém eu tenho
um amigo que tem aquele sonho pode ser
de escrever um livro de abrir uma
empresa de aprender um novo idioma ou
até mesmo emagrecer mas a minha pergunta
sempre fui porque para a maioria das
pessoas
esses sonhos não se tornaram realidade
se eu te disser que entre você escolher
receber um milhão de reais
hoje vou receber um centavo que vai
dobrando por 30 dias e todas essas metas
que isso têm uma coisa em comum
você acredita em mim é sobre isso que eu
vou falar com vocês
a primeira vez que eu tivesse insight na
minha vida foi maio de 2013
eu estava sentado no meu computador
nos estados unidos isso aconteça e eu
recebi esse erro
quando recebi esse meio
a primeira coisa que eu pensei que era
mentira
eu não estava conseguindo acreditar eu
olhava pra tela não fazia sentido eu
estudar isto for não tinha palavras era
sempre um sonho sempre foi apaixonado
por tecnologia e está perto das empresas
que mais admiro isso me deixa sem
palavras
se você não está acreditando que estou
falando olha a cara de feliz desse
menino no primeiro dia ele mal sabia o
que estava por vir
durante todo esse tempo e se eu for eu
conheci várias pessoas sensacionais mas
eu tive dois amigos que juntos numa
conversa
nós tivemos uma idéia nós fomos
bolsistas do ciência sem fronteiras que
nós pensamos por que não pegar a nossa
experiência e usar aquilo para
transformar a vida de milhares de
pessoas e ajudar com que outras pessoas
também tivessem um melhor intercâmbio da
vida delas
e foi assim pensando nisso que surgiu
mais csf
no começo foi um projeto pequeno a gente
ajudava uma mensagem aqui um grupo do
facebook até que um dia resolvi tomar o
controle da situação e decidir isso aqui
seria uma empresa e quando aquilo virou
uma empresa as coisas começaram a
crescer de verdade era palestra pelo
brasil inteiro era milhares de pessoas
baixando os guias que a gente criava
para conseguir ajudar as pessoas
teve mais de 500 mil pessoas acessando o
nosso site teve visita para brasília
para falar no evento com o presidente
e pra finalizar com chave de ouro eu
consegui uma coisa que eu tinha como
sonho na minha vida de empreendedor que
nós conseguimos ser capa de um dos
maiores jornais
contando o nosso projeto ea nossa
história
nesse momento eu comecei a sentir que eu
era úmidas que tudo que eu fizesse ia
dar certo
qualquer coisa qualquer projeto só vai
saber na academia o cross fit qualquer
coisa e para ser muito sincero com vocês
foi isso que aconteceu por alguns meses
as coisas foram andando a empresa
crescendo e eu não fazia nada mas a
empresa continuará crescendo até que eu
tive uma brilhante idéia se tem uma
empresa que funciona é bom porque não
ter duas eu peguei a desenhar se essa
ideia de uma nova empresa procura um
sócio eu vi que precisava de dinheiro
eu tinha um dinheirinho guardado que se
desce tudo errado como é se essa reserva
peguei esse gerenciador precisava de
mais um pouco
daí eu fui atrás duas pessoas que nunca
falaram pra mim meu pai ea minha mãe
cheguei para ele e falei 'pai 31 que
entender o direito que eu fazia na
internet sabe
pai eu tenho uma idéia é que a empresa
que eu fiz então ela cresceu foi
sensacional foi até capa de jornal né
eu toco mais uma idéia eu quero fazer um
negócio novo diferente
só que eu preciso da sua ajuda empresta
dinheiro
ele ficou meio assim uma pergunta ou
outra mas no final emprestou de 80
aquele dinheiro do meu pai o meu
dinheiro e comecei a abrir a nova
empresa estava tudo lindo milhão eu tava
sentir aquela adrenalina de novo de
criar uma nova empresa era marketing pra
cá palestra pra cá curso vendido
mobiliando escritório eu estava ficando
apaixonado por como aquela escola que a
gente estava criando estava ficando dois
dias antes de lançar a nossa primeira
turma começarem as aulas dessa primeira
turma o meu sócio me chamou e me falou
peró
[Música]
não dá mais pra mim do jeito que está
não tá bom um olho no olho dele e eu
travei
eu não consegui xingar eu não conseguia
falar tudo que eu tava pensando
simplesmente travei aquele projeto
aquela idéia a não existia se ele era
professor principal é a chave de tudo e
sem ele eu quebrei quando eu quebrei
eu me recordo que está deitado na cama
um mês depois eu digo um mês porque
nesse período desde a conversa com ele
até agora não consigo saber o que
aconteceu na minha vida eu não tenho uma
lembrança não consigo imaginar como foi
minha vida nesse período eu estava
isolado sem chão eu estava totalmente
sem energia
eu estava deitado naquela cama pensando
poxa agora eu não tenho empresa
eu não tenho dinheiro e as duas
principais pessoas que poderiam me
ajudar com isso eu estava fugindo dela o
tempo inteiro
eu não queria ter que fazer uma ligação
para o meu pai pra minha mãe para contar
o que tinha acontecido que eu tinha
falhado o que tinha mudado tudo errado
que eles confiaram em mim e eu quebrei
foi nesse momento que eu achei que nunca
mais ia conseguir sair daquilo
até que no dia seguinte eu deitado na
cama o celular do lado tocou o barulho
de um e mail nossa passou o tempo já que
eu ficava feliz quando isso acontecia
quando eu peguei aquele meio a primeira
frase que eu vi
era muito obrigado pela sua ajuda a não
é possível é spam um ressentido dentro
de água ajuda porque mas mesmo assim
continuei lendo muito obrigado pela sua
ajuda peró
eu me chamo gabriel e eu fiz um dos
cursos que você ofertou como ssf e isso
transformou a minha vida e isso fez com
que eu visse o mundo de uma forma
totalmente diferente
eu só queria te agradecer e aproveitando
se você tiver um tempo vão bater um papo
naquele momento eu entendi
eu olhei pra ele por outro lado estava
na cama eu falei não pára aí
esse pessoal que fica deitado na cama
não foi o peru começou tudo o piloto
começou tudo ele não começou para ele
ficar sentindo bem
ele acha que ele era bom que as coisas
eram boas pra ele operou começou tudo
ele começou a ajudar os outros
se você ficar deitado isso não vai
ajudar ninguém e aí eu entendi que uma
idéia um projeto com uma empresa não é
feito pra fazer você ser maior não é
feito para levantar seu ego é feito para
transformar a vida das pessoas
e se você conseguir com a sua ideia o
seu projeto transformar em pelo menos um
por cento a vida de uma pessoa se pode
considerar que o seu objetivo de vida
foi realizado nesse momento feliz
lembrando toda essa energia eu peguei
responde um e mail do gabriel tudo que
eu queria agradecer naquele momento e
nós conversamos gabriel me contou uma
série de coisas contou que ele gostou do
curso e com tom e pra finalizar falou
peró
eu tô querendo impactar pessoas vamos
levamo então vamos fazer um livro falei
vamos fechar vão escrever um livro eu
desliguei o telefone falei ele falou que
a gente vai escrever um livro é possível
não faço ideia como escreveu o livro eu
não estou vendo aqui pra vocês porque eu
fiquei feliz não estava assustado eu não
sou escritor
mas por mais assustado que eu tivesse a
sensação de estar de volta no jogo
já preço a sensação de ter uma meta um
objetivo eu peguei tudo isso eu sentei
na frente do computador e eu escrevi e
eu escrevi e eu escrevi como eu nunca
escrevi na minha vida
o segundo dia eu fiz a mesma coisa eu
escrevi e reescrevi escrevi no terceiro
pensei poxa eu escrevi tanto né
posso ficar a dormir um pouco mais hoje
no quarto oitavo dia de sol para quem
escreveu num dia de sol
vamos por partes só que no dia 10 no 14º
dia eu percebi que fazem é fazer 10 dias
que ela escrevia início eu escutei
aquele pessoal da cama falando você tá
vendo as coisas não dão certo porque
está fazendo tudo isso desisti agora dói
muito menos eu lembrei que nunca mais na
minha vida eu queria ser aquela pessoa
nunca mais eu queria me sentir como eu
sentir que não precisava fazer uma coisa
foi que começou a vasculhar começa a
entender todo o meu passado eu comecei a
entender o que deu certo eo que deu
errado
procurei e meio fui ver projeto tudo o
que tinha acontecido no passado eu
encontrei nada eu encontrei umas coisas
que foi um motivo único para tudo isso
acontecer mas eu descobri que tinha duas
coisas que eu fazia muito bem eu fazia
as coisas todos os dias sem desculpa e
também eu todo dia fazia o que precisava
ser feito
mesmo aquelas tarefas mais chatas do
mundo eu fazia com o tempo eu comecei a
estudar eu descobri que fazer as coisas
todos os dias se chama consistência e
fazer as coisas mesmo das coisas que
você odeia se chama resiliência mas
peraí que o click consistência
resiliência 1% melhor a cada dia essa
fórmula de tudo foi aí que eu descobrir
qualquer meu super poder o que eu sabia
fazer direito
mas eu sabia disso mas como eu aplicaria
então toda
a idéia para escrever um livro
eu decidi que pelos próximos meses
eu ia sentar todo o dia na frente do
computador
ia passar pelo menos duas horas
escrevendo e não importando a minha
vontade de itália ou não eu também
decidi que todo dia
faça chuva ou faça sol eu daria pelo
menos um passo em direção ao que tem
aquele livro publicado o resultado disso
foi fabuloso e 30 dias
eu escrevi um livro ou melhor eu escrevi
um livro em 30 dias
eu queria um escritor uma coisa que eu
nunca esperava e como eu falei pra vocês
não era nada excepcional eu não era
ninguém eu descobri que eu não tenho
nada de diferente
foi nesse momento que entende que
qualquer pessoa pode fazer as coisas se
esforçar e tiver a disciplina adequada
se você ainda não conseguiu acreditar
nisso eu quero te dar duas formas para
você aprender como você pode ser um por
cento o melhor a cada dia
a primeira coisa que você pode fazer
sempre é que o fato de você se tornar um
por cento o melhor a cada dia
deve ser um compromisso seu assim como
se sabe quando você tem uma reunião com
seu chefe o gol mais importante com você
pode acontecer o que for
você não desmarca aquela região porém
quando você tem uma reunião com a pessoa
mais importante do mundo você quando
surge a primeira dificuldade 1 6 metro
pode ser aquela reunião sua para acordar
mais cedo e ir pra academia ou então
chegar no fim do dia aprender um
pouquinho mais um novo idioma ou
qualquer outra coisa
então faça com que o fato de você ser um
por cento melhora a cada dia seja um
compromisso pra você
a segunda coisa que você pode fazer
é que todo dia quando você colocar a sua
cabeça no travesseiro
você precisa pensar a minha versão de
hoje foi 1% melhor que a de ontem e pode
ser em qualquer área
pode ser na sua saúde na sua alimentação
na sua produtividade no trabalho
relacionamentos qualquer coisa você só
precisa ser 1% melhor se isso tudo ainda
não convenceu você eu quero mostrar uma
coisa se você for um por cento melhor a
cada dia durante um ano você vai ser 37
vezes melhor
quem está falando isso não é operou é
matemática
esse mesmo a matemática não te convencer
eu trouxe uma pessoa que vai te
convencer e era essa pessoa que estaria
apresentando essa palestra
se eu não tivesse esforçado para ser 1%
melhor a cada dia
fala galera eu sou peyrol esse é o
segundo vídeo da série a3 habilidades e
todo golfista definir fronteiras deve
ter aproveitar o máximo intercâmbio
nós somos parecidos
uma pena que não tem mais aquela blusa
[Música]
mas agora é a hora que eu quero que cada
um de vocês eu quero que você faça
surreal escolha o que você quer de
verdade para sua vida você é o que você
quer um milhão de reais
agora você quer receber um centavo que
vai dobrando por 30 dias
caso você tenha escolhido a segunda
opção
o final desse período você vai ter 5,3
milhões
na minha opinião isso é um pouco mais do
que um milhão e eu te desafio então a
fazer uma coisa se você quer fazer parte
disso quero fazer parte desse clube
descer 1 por cento melhor a cada dia eu
te desafio agora a pegar seu celular
não é pra pegar de verdade o celular
eu quero que você desbloqueie e que você
anote no seu celular
o que você vai fazer amanhã para ser um
por cento melhor em que horário porque
eu já notei meu compromisso e ele vai
ser ajudar você a 100% melhor todo dia
obrigado
[Aplausos]